mais vous étiez prêt à creuser une
piscine pour les pingouins alors oui ben
j'ai acheté directement une piscine
gauflampe je dirais que j'aime bien de
m'habiller en pingouin quand je reçois
certaines personnalité quoi des gens qui
viennent visiter le
musée ce musée alors il a commencé
comment ben c'est dû à une infirmité que
j'ai contracté en étant militaire de
derrière j'ai eu tout le côté gauche
abîmé j'ai été réformé je faisais le
chauffeur de taxi et un beau jour Dieu à
M démarche un client m renommé VI
pingouin après al il m'a offert un petit
pingouin qu'on vendait à la mer je l'
mis dans la voiture le deuxième pingouin
c'est un pingouin que j'ai sollicité
auprès d'une cliente au lieu de lui
faire payer le prix de la course j'ai
demandé le pingouin et maintenant j'
possède 1674 pingouin
différents
disons qu'au début c'était un r c'est
devenu une collection c'est devenu une
passion pour le jour d'aujourd'hui c'est
une
obsess vous pensez qu' pingouin rêvez de
pingouin oui oui oui ou concernant ça
oui ça je ne vois ça je ne vois que les
pingouins quoi mon rêve pour moi ce
serait d'aller faire une expédition qui
[Musique]
Antarctique ques sont les pièces qui
vous intéressent le plus dans collection
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de mieux qu'est-ce
c'est ce qu'on me pose tout le temps la
même chose mais pour moi que ce soit du
plus petit jusqu'au plus grand ou ou du
plus beau jusqu'au plus il y en a qui
sont pas si beau que ça mais ils me
plaisent tous Je tiis pas mettre un de
[Musique]
haut vous n'avez pas encore de pingouin
vivant non pas du tout j'aurais bien
aimé un coupe de pingouin alors il vous
faut déjà une installation plus ou moins
adéquate quoi il faut une piscine il
faut des petites grottes avec une pierre
qui garde une certaine humidité pour
quand il fait trop chaud quoi ah oui
mais vous étiez prêt à creuser une
piscine pour les pingouins alors oui ben
j'ai acheté directement une piscine
gauflampe c'est un cri aigu ou et ça je
ne sais pas le faire vous avez pas
essayé jamais non non non je laisse ça à
ma femme ah bon parce que vot femme
votre femme elle aime pas beaucoup les
pingouins pas du tout elle en a
bon le costume que j'ai justement sur
moi quand je viens mourir on me met mon
costume on MRE avec mon costume et je
suis en pour parler ici pour avec ma
pierbal un pingouin dessus et alors à ce
moment-là on écrit Alfred David 10
pingouins le 4 du533 et la date quand je
serai mort mais je vais je vais ici
prochainement m'arranger pour faire
sculpter le couvercle de mon cercueil
[Musique]